- Welcome come to this special
episode of Firm Learning
if you wish this is Firm
Learning breaking news
because I trust that
many of you might already
have seen the document
from a set of first year
Goldman Sachs analysts the was
not published that was leaked
and is currently making
it around the internet.
So lots of major news
publications have already
talked about it so in this video,
I wanna do the following thing
we will now jointly
look into this document
from these first year
Goldman Sachs analysts.
And I reflect on that
based on my experience
as a former McKinsey consultant
and I will also contrast
that of how this compares
to working in a tier one
consulting firm to working
in an MBB consulting firms
like McKinsey, BCG or Bain
or anything of the like.
So let's dig into it
so to get to this deck
I just Googled Goldman Sachs
working conditions survey
and then somewhere here it appears.
So this is the document
that everybody is now indeed
talking about, so let's have a look.
So what does it say
working condition survey
from Goldman Sachs February, 2021.
So apparently also just
to be very clear here
apparently this is not officially
been released by Goldman
but rather was created
by a set of analysts
that they then used and
apparently then also distributed
to the media I don't
know the details of this,
but where they then talk
about the working conditions
at that firm.
And here of course it
really gets juicy, right?
So it says on average, first
year analysts are working
over 95 hours per week and
sleeping five hours per night.
And specifically when
they're asked about how much
they worked in the last week,
they said that they worked
hundred and five hours.
And this is just crazy because indeed
if you do the calculation
this really means that
these people pretty much work
every Saturday, every Sunday.
And from my friends who work
in these very large banks
in Frankfurt or London,
I know that this is
actually the case, right?
So it's really expected,
and many of these firms,
again, don't want to say anything
about the specifics and Goldman Sachs.
But just in general, what
I have heard from people
working there apparently these
people really are expected
to come into the office every
Saturday and every Sunday.
And if you are regular
watcher of my channel
you might have already
seen this video that I did
on the regular work week of a consultant.
I will insert it somewhere above here
but if you have seen that
you know that actually
this is usually not expected
from you in consulting.
So based on my former
employer, I know that
there was a very strong
culture of not working at all
on the weekend, on Saturday, on Sunday.
Of course then this also relates to sleep
and then at the time where you go to sleep
and apparently here, this was 3:00 am.
So they say that they
sleep five hours per night.
So I had some weeks in consulting
where really the workload
was quite high and are also only 3:00 am
where I went to bed.
And also a couple of weeks
where really only slept
five hours on average in that week,
so this happened occasionally
but this was for sure or not the average.
This was really the absolute
spike, the absolute outlier
the baseline was much less than that,
than what is shown here.
Okay next, near term
retention, so the question here
always if conditions stay the same,
What is the likelihood
you stay with the firm
in one month and three
months and then six months.
From one to 10, 10 is high, one is low.
And of course here you are
considered based on that
the likelihood that they
will still be at the firm
in six months, it's not that high.
You know I would argue that this is sick
given the conditions that are described.
Still a rather high value, right?
So apparently this forum
does seem to offer something
to these people that
at least in some extent
might seem it maybe not bearable
but somehow compensate for
what they're experiencing.
Right. But for sure,
this is not looking good.
Your next one effect on
physical and mental health.
So how does your mental
health change before
and after the job?
And here as well, what is the development
of your physical health
before and after the job.
And both of them this is
what you see here also
right up from one to 10.
10 is the best with a
significant decrease.
So for sure, balancing working
in consulting with sports
with a healthy lifestyle
can be challenging
but if you really make this
a priority, it is possible.
And personally, I made it
also a priority of trying
to do at least the one
time sport during the week,
during the work week.
I even try to do it twice every work week.
So didn't happen every single time,
it didn't record every single time
but I made it happen quite frequently.
So next, what else are they saying?
So, here the question,
how have your work hours
negatively impacted relationships
with family and friends?
They all said yes, there
was some negative impact.
And here, I must say
probably also in consulting,
it's really difficult to
say that work in consulting
will not have any negative
effect on your relationships
with family and friends,
because of course the truth
is that in consulting.
your normal work week
is just like from Monday to Thursday
you're not at home, but
you're working client side.
And then of course, if
you don't see your family
and friends the whole
week, this is difficult.
And especially if you have a
family, this then usually means
that you're not seeing your children
from Monday to Thursday,
this can really be tough.
And here may be the bankers
even have the advantage
because even though they come home late,
at least they come home every night.
Then probably it's not that much of a use
if you're really only sleep at 3:00 AM
and then need to get out in
the morning again. Right.
But here I'd say consulting,
isn't much better I must say.
Then next, if you've been
a victim of workplace abuse
and you have big, big majority says yes.
And here I must say, this is
for sure not the atmosphere
that I've experienced in consulting.
So in consulting, people
are really focusing a lot
on treating everybody professionally,
on treating everybody with respect.
So as always, there are also
always outliers here as well.
And for sure, you will
always have some examples
of people who cannot behave
themselves or whatever.
But for sure, this is not
systemic to the environment
in consulting.
I'd rather I use exactly
the opposite way around
based on my experiences.
I have seen everybody treated
with highest levels of respect.
So have you frequently
experienced unrealistic deadlines
shunned, ignored in
meetings, unwarranted invalid
or public criticism.
And here, especially for the first two,
a lot of yes here for banking.
So unrealistic deadlines,
I mean unrealistic is of
course a relative fear, right?
But tough deadlines for
sure is what you will face
in consulting as well.
So here I'd argue probably very similar
and also unwarranted and
valid or public criticism.
Of course this is always
very relative as well
in subject to fraud so,
properly very rarely,
somebody gets very, very tough
criticism who will say yes.
This was hundred percent
absolutely justified.
I mean, of course there
are these instances
but this were not the norm.
So it's a bit difficult, but for sure
where I'd say it's different in consulting
is that you are shunned
and ignored in meetings.
This is not what I've seen.
My experiences that really from day one
from being a first week young
junior analyst in consulting,
you will be encouraged to
sit in client meetings.
Not only sit in client meetings,
but actively participate
and very quickly also,
lead this meetings too.
This is, I'd say a big difference.
You will be really be thrown in the water
very, very quickly.
And we would just expected to
just run in these meetings,
to lead them, to guide them,
to have these client interactions.
So this apparently does
seem to be different here.
Here it just goes on and on
blaming without justification,
shouting or swearing, excessive monitoring
or micromanagement.
Here I just wanna emphasize my point
especially on the shouting or swearing.
Again, there are always
outliers, but this for sure
is not the norm in consulting.
And to also to be fair,
also, your only minority
seems to regularly experience
these things in banking.
So other things, how satisfied are you
with a firm work life, personal life,
no surprise that apparently
people aren't that satisfied.
Now, if you were to
move on to another role
how likely would you
recommend Goldman Sachs?
Here's typically quite
high interestingly enough
and I guess you can read, I
don't find this interesting.
And now one slide that is just crazy.
I mean, Oh wow.
This is so bad.
I mean, just to read this.
I don't even wanna read all this out,
but just the first one.
The sleep deprivation, the
treatment by senior bankers,
the mental and physical
stress I've been through
foster care, and this is arguably worse.
(breathes loudly) This is bad.
This is really bad.
I mean then the other
ones is where my body
physically hurts all the time.
And mentally, I'm in a really dark place.
I didn't come into this job
expecting a 9:00 am to 5:00 pm
but I also didn't expect consistent
9:00 am to 5:00 am's either.
And here you can just, you know,
read the rest for yourself.
This is just crazy.
And again, I trust that,
you can already sense this
from what I've said earlier
but this is not what the reality
in consulting looks like.
Again, I, by no means,
want to glorify working in consulting.
It can be really tough
and challenging as well,
but not like this.
I promise you maybe there
are some peaks, a week
or maybe also two or three weeks,
which can be really, really tough
depending on the types
of projects that you do.
But this for sure will
not be the baseline,
and even on the toughest weeks
you will not consistently
work from 9:00 am to 5:00 am.
This is what I've never
seen happen only once
on any of the projects that I worked at.
This is just what I can say.
And in the end also, interestingly enough,
they have some suggestions on what to do
to rectify the situation and here as well,
I don't want to go too
much into the detail
but just hear the first one.
So 80 hours per week should
be considered max capacity.
So their demand is to
work 80 hours per week.
And again, just to contrast
this with consulting
I'd argue the problem,
the average in consulting
it's around 60 to 65 hours per weeks.
And with ups and downs there will be weeks
where you will also
work more than 80 hours,
but for sure, this is not the baseline.
So it is fair to say
that apparently working
in investment banking
seems to be a bit tougher
at least at this specific
form if this is true,
than working in consulting.
Of course now you could also argue that
of course the salary will
be a bit higher in banking
especially also in the long term,
it would be higher in
banking than in consulting.
And yeah, if you just want
to read the rest, feel free.
So this is just some
reflections on my end,
I'd be super happy to hear
from you in the comments.
Are you working in a
bank or in consulting?
Does this resonate? Does this make sense?
Maybe you're some insiders
from GS or some other firms?
Let us know what it's really like,
whether this is really the case.
And if you've never
watched this channel before
my name is Heinrich from learning.
I'm a former McKinsey consultant.
Usually on my channel I talk
about how to be successful
in the first years of your career.
I share tips on slide writing,
creating presentations
how to behave in meetings,
how to structure your work.
So all of these things that I learned
during my past work experience where I try
to help you with your work life as well.
So looking forward,
usually I release videos
every single Saturday, this
was only a bonus video.
So looking forward to that. Cheers,
this is Heinrich from learning. Bye-bye.